well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world class performers to tease out the
thought processes the best practices the
influences
and so on that you can hopefully copy
and paste into your own life in some
fashion
to test out the toolkits of people who
are the best at what they do
my guest this episode is a return guest
josh waitzkin he was in fact the second
ever guest in episode two of this
podcast
we've known each other a long time josh
wadeskin is author of
the art of learning he is an eight-time
us national chess champion a two-time
world champion tai chi push hands
and the first brazilian jiu jitsu black
belt under nine nine-time world champion
marcelo garcia widely believed
to be the greatest grappler who has ever
lived at least
in the world of bjj for the past 12
years maybe 13 maybe 14 now josh has
been channeling his passion
for the outer limits of the learning
process towards training
elite mental performers in business and
finance
or finance if you prefer and to
revolutionizing the education system
through his non-profit foundation the
art of learning project
josh is currently in the process of
taking on his fourth and fifth
disciplines
paddle surfing and foiling josh is
always
a fantastic thought partner he is
constantly
pushing back at anything that i say
which reflects
sloppy thinking or imprecise thinking or
consensus thinking
and he's a lovely guy so please enjoy
this wide-ranging conversation with
none other than josh wadeskin
this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer end quote that's
the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights up and down
with the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still
getting a tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
the four hour body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that and the other thing
and after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
tonal also has a growing library of
expert lead workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects of
the engineering and smart features check
your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www www.tonal.com for 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by viori
clothing spelled v-u-o-r-i
viori i've been wearing viori at least
one item per day for the last few months
and you can use it for everything
it's performance apparel but it can be
used for working out
it can be used for going out to dinner
at least in my case
i feel very comfortable with it super
comfortable super stylish
and i just want to read something that
one of my employees said she is
an athlete she is quite technical
although she would never say that i
asked her if she had ever
used or heard of vyori and this was her
response
i do love their stuff been using them
for about a year i think i found them at
rei first for my partner
t-shirts that are super soft but somehow
last as he's hard on stuff and then i
got into the super soft cotton yoga
pants and jogger
sweatpants i live in them and they too
have lasted they're stylish enough i can
wear them out and about the material is
just super soft and durable
i just got their clementine running
shorts for summer and love them the
brand seems pretty popular constantly
sold out in closing and i'm abbreviating
here but in closing
with the exception of when i need
technical outdoor gear they're the only
brand i've bought in the last year or so
for yoga
running loungewear that lasts and that i
think look good also
i like the discrete logo so that gives
you
some idea that was not intended for the
sponsor read
that was just her response via text
viori again spelled v-u-o-r-i
is designed for maximum comfort and
versatility you can wear it running you
can wear their stuff
training doing yoga lounging weekend
errands
or in my case again going out to dinner
it really doesn't matter what you're
doing
their clothing is so comfortable and
looks so good and it's it's
non-offensive that you don't have a huge
brand logo in your face you'll just want
to be in them all the time and my
girlfriend and i have been wearing them
for the last few months they're men's
core short kore
the most comfortable lined athletic
short is your one short for every sport
i've been using it for kettlebell swings
for
runs you name it the banks short this is
their go to land
to see short is the ultimate in
versatility it's made from recycled
plastic bottles and what i'm wearing
right now
which i had to pick one to recommend to
folks out there or at least to men out
there is the ponto performance
pant and you'll find these at the link
i'm going to give you guys
you can check out what i'm talking about
but i'm wearing them right now
they're thin performance sweatpants but
that doesn't do them justice so you
gotta check it out ponto ponto
performance pant
for you ladies the women's performance
jogger is the softest jaw girl you'll
ever own
viori isn't just an investment your
clothing it's an investment in your
happiness and for you
my dear listeners they're offering 20
off your first purchase
so get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet
it's super popular a lot of my friends
have now noticed are wearing this
and so my viori clothing dot com forward
slash tim that's
v u o r i clothing dot com
slash tim not only will you receive 20
off your first purchase
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on
any u.s orders over 75
dollars and free returns so check it out
viori clothing dot com slash tim that's
v-u-o-r-i
clothing dot com slash tim and discover
the versatility
of the ore clothing
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
we have beautiful osa
dutch shepherd of small stature next to
us
growing quickly with josh waitzkin
polymath
of medium stature this is the tim
ferriss show
i'm tim ferriss and uh josh baby
it's good to see you again that's an
interesting label
polymath of medium stature okay
jimbo that's good i like it
i've got excellent coffee strong
to fuel our conversation i feel good
about this whole thing
me too i'm gonna turn the tables on you
a little bit
yeah let's get into it so our plan here
is for
me to interview tim a little bit open up
some
questions and we've been having a
beautiful few weeks of dialogue
over meals in ice and ice plunges and
saunas last bunch of days have been
really intense conversation
one of the patterns that i find really
powerful in our dialogue is that when we
talk about
ideas and potential projects you
consistently
have the ability to ask gating questions
that frame
the discussion differently and i tend to
think i'm pretty good at that but what i
find
surprising is how and one thing i love
is that when when i bring ideas to you
you take it to another level and it's
consistently jolting
and after our conversations i often look
at something quite differently and
i love that and so how would you
deconstruct your your relationship to
gating questions
how do you approach them let's do deep
dive first
could you define or describe for me what
a gating question is
if we're talking about an idea or let's
just say someone were to approach you
with a project that they're thinking
about
you tend to go at it with first
principles and you have a way of
approaching the subject
with a different framing i observe your
approach exposes like in the david
foster wallace this is water
right people a fish isn't aware of its
water you
are very good at showing people what
their water is and you have a way of
of tackling the subject that they've
been thinking about for days or weeks or
months or years
and very quickly showing them angles of
it that that they haven't considered
and i've watched you do that with a lot
of people i think it's one of your power
zones
and i just thought it'd be really cool
for you to talk about how you approach
it
yeah this is fun i i don't often talk
about this
or i suppose even think about it
explicitly
when i talk to
folks who are presenting an idea a plan
hope a goal i think the first thing that
i do
and this is probably honed over many
many many years of getting
pitched hundreds of times with startups
is there are a few stock questions
so i think i cheat in that respect i
have a handful of
triage tools that i use on the intake so
if somebody comes in
it's kind of like are you having trouble
breathing
let me check your pulse let me check
your vitals there are a few questions
like that that i use
repeatedly one would be asking someone
what assumptions they are making
to see if they're even consciously aware
of the assumptions that are being made
which is also a really good test
to see how rigorously they've examined
other aspects of whatever the plan or
goal might be
what makes this attractive right like
what are the aspects of this that you
assume to be true that make this
attractive if it's an idea or something
like that
the answer they give or don't give right
it's kind of like the sherlock holmes
the case of the dog not barking like
sometimes it's an answer they don't give
that that really
says a lot and removes the need for a
lot of follow-ups another one that i ask
all the time and i think this is in part
because i get asked
a lot about writing books i'm thinking
about writing a book
or i'm about to start writing a book or
i'm going to be selling a book
and i've talked to dozens of friends
about this
and the way i pose it and this this will
sound familiar
is i'll ask them you know if it takes
twice as long
and you get half the rewards or a
quarter of the rewards
and it's not a best seller is this still
a no-brainer for you and the wording
there is really important
the no-brainer part is important it's
not is it still a good idea because a
good idea could be
pro and con list and you come to the
conclusion 51
good 49 bad yes it's a good idea that's
different from a no-brainer
right if it's a whole body yes so this
question is is fishing for how intrinsic
the motivation is
it's fishing for how intrinsic the
motivation is it's also
fishing for a few other things so
the first might be worded a different
way in the case of books like is it
easier to write the book than to not
write the book for me i rarely
there are different motivations for
writing books they're different
catalysts but for me
usually i can't find something i'm
looking for and it bothers me so much
that i i just have to write the goddamn
thing because
i'm not gonna have it otherwise and in
that respect it's easier for me to write
it than to not write it
because it bothers me so much that it's
not written in some way
the other is taking into account
all of the things outside of our control
right you could
put the perfect plan into motion
you could write an outstanding
book just a genre defining you know
category killing
book and then 9 11 happens the week of
year book launch
and nobody ever sees your book in effect
because it's crowded out
there's so many things outside of our
control i mean certainly the last years
highlighted that and so i want to know
are you going to in some
sense find reward and gratification
and edification through the process in
case a curveball hits you
square in the face because it's
it's not a black swan event i mean it's
very common that this happens
if you just come out in the wrong week
in the case of books
so those are those are two questions
and then for me i think
in the last handful of years in
particular thinking of
energy management over time management
has led me to
think of experiments that can be done
that might be alternatives to what
people are considering
that allow them an easier termination
clause
if that makes any sense i'm using that
metaphorically but it's sometimes very
easy to get into plans and then you have
employees or you have a company or you
have your identity
potentially wrapped up in something that
has gone out and now you
feel like you can't remove yourself or
shut it down because it will be viewed
as a failure
and so to mitigate against all those
things i'm constantly looking for
cheap fast ways to test how can you test
your assumptions
how can you test your assumptions about
the upside
how can you test your assumptions about
the downside how can we find comparables
have you spoken to any of the people who
are at the helm of x y and z
at those comparables i really
don't view myself as a risk taker even
though at points i've had that
label or reputation but i i view myself
as first and foremost like a
massive risk mitigator i do a lot of
testing
so those are those are a few things so
if you were to invert that
if you think back on to all those
conversations you've had with people
pitching you on something
if you were to take their perspective
what do you think the patterns would be
and what those people said about
the insights they gained from the
conversation not the tactics
but the insights about themselves and
how they relate to their project
so i look at everything with an
editorial eye
which is part of the reason why i almost
never read friends manuscripts because i
can't just give them
a paragraph of feedback i'll end up
copying the whole goddamn thing
so when i look at a deck like a
pitch deck and then i go down a level
deeper and i look at
the bios of the people involved i spot
weaknesses and red flags that would turn
off
oftentimes other investors they want
involved or the types of investors they
would want involved
so i get to see i'm answering this
somewhat indirectly but i i get to see
also how founders in the case of
startups but this could apply to almost
anything this could apply to books also
book ideas could apply to any idea
how people respond to constructive
criticism
and what's really interesting about not
just startups
but book ideas business ideas
career switching ideas that people have
is very often
people around them feel like
support means giving positive feedback
so they their baby even if it's ugly
never gets called ugly
and then i come in and i'm like well
first thing i noticed
is uh you know on the first page of your
deck you misspelled
profile it might seem like a minor thing
but
i would fix that it's low hanging fruit
it's easy to fix you know
and that's not a massive correction
but i get to see how people respond to
that the other question
or another question there are a lot of
questions i like to ask but
this is a question i was asked in the
last year i want to say
i can't recall the source but it's not
mine i mean i borrow
i borrow most of what i use and ask
the question is flash forward three
years
the company has failed
what went wrong right what is the most
likely reason the company will have
failed
also if it's due to an incorrect
assumption which
assumption do you think is most likely
to be wrong and
if someone can't answer that or is
unwilling to answer that because they're
getting a lot of adulation
and they have more
say in the case of a startup they have
more demand
in other words investor interest than
supply
that's definitely a red flag for me so
what people get to see then if they
really take those questions seriously
and assuming someone else hasn't asked
those questions
is they very often find
blind spots that are real risks they're
risks that they have not accounted for
right like most authors think if i or
potential authors
if i get the right publisher if i have
the right distribution and i write an
amazing book
it is inevitable that the book will do
well if i follow a few guidelines for
launch
if i'm on a big show and that's just not
true yeah
so building on this one of the themes
that i spend a good deal thinking about
is the entanglement of genius and
eccentricity
i think that most of the the great
performers that i've
known or competed against or worked with
in different fields have just had this
beautiful
connection between their areas of
dysfunctionality
and brilliance sometimes
the very thing that helps them excel in
their professional life or their
artistic life or their competitive life
is something that in their personal life
can be a little bit awkward
right or sometimes very awkward or
something's very awkward
and it can be extremely subtle and it
can be
fascinating like you know the recent
study of usain bolt's
stride and the fact that it's uneven
people would
might want to normalize it but then you
can think about how the unevenness of
his
leg length or spinal construction might
actually be part of why he is so fast
right and you can think about this
i think about a great deal with marcelo
garcia and he and i have been having a
fun conversation about this theme over
the past few days yeah so for people who
don't know i'm just a sentence or two on
marcelo well we've spoken about marcelo
so much yeah so
marcelo is the nine-time um submission
grappling and brazilian jiu-jitsu world
champion he's probably
i would argue pound for pound the
greatest grappler martial arts grappler
to ever live
and he's a dear friend of mine we own a
school together in new york and i've
trained with him for
a decade plus really exquisite learner
and a really interesting eccentric
learner
and anyway this theme of the
entanglement of genius and eccentricity
is one that i find
to be liberating for people because
there's a big pressure to normalize
oneself how does that show up for
marcelo
or why did you bring him up after usain
bolt well i think marcelo is at a
similar
league in a similar league in terms of
dominance of his field and he's someone
who's really
built a game around his idiosyncrasies
in a beautiful way i mean he's uh he's
both physically he's
physically small short short limbs
has built an incredible technical
repertoire that really revolutionized
the brazilian jitsu world based on his
body type and the idiosyncrasies of his
personality the way his mind works his
incredibly overdeveloped somatic
intelligence versus his
many years ago lack of conceptual
relationship to what he was doing
for example one of the remarkable things
about marcelo is
the way he repeats mistakes less than
anyone i've ever known
it's incredible whether it's a technical
mistake a psychological mistake
and i've observed this i've felt this
with him i mean when he and i have you
know we've spent hundreds of hours
grappling
sparring fighting on the mats and like
you catch marcelo with something one
time and you don't catch him with it
again
and that's just not true about people
it's it's incredible
usually it's the opposite yeah you can
you've exploited a weakness like when i
got guillotined 77 times in a row
right at your school we had a good time
with that one
so but like but the amazing thing about
for example how that manifests in
marcelo's life is
that you know as he's told me in really
powerful moments of conversation
he experiences pain
really viscerally he experiences pain
and he never his body never forgets it
in his life and it's true on the mats
and so there's an area of
that could really make life painful
right but that is
incredibly powerful in his life and i
think there's a lot relative to myself
as well this this entanglement but i was
curious to open up with you when you you
know people obviously
you have a public life and you and i
mostly interact outside of your public
life
in just the eccentric nature of our of
our friendship
meeting up in the jungle for weeks at a
time and having great conversations and
i have my own perspective on this
but i'm curious how you would talk about
you're so admired in the world and
people are
people have think a lot about your
brilliance and your ability to
deconstruct and how
how much insight you have how would you
describe the underbelly of that what's
the
what's the shadow of it how does that
brilliance
manifest in your personal life where
where are the areas of eccentricity or
dysfunctionality that people might not
see
yeah i think i think the word i'm glad
you used the word dysfunctionality
because sometimes
like eccentricity can be used as a
substitute
a nice substitute for crazy when
somebody is
successful in a given field
so it's true but different adjectives
sometimes apply to the same thing
depending on how well someone is
done by luck or design or both
it shows up a lot shows up a lot in many
many different ways
and i've thought about this quite
a bit because there have been times when
i've
wanted to there still are times i think
warranted times when i want to fix
certain dysfunctionality
and there is a occasionally a fear that
in attempting to snuff out those areas
of dysfunction or those
exhibitions of eccentricity that i'll
also snuff out
whatever the pixie dust is that allows
me to do certain things
this is very true i know for a lot of
comedians for instance
they some comedians don't want to get
therapy they don't want to fix the pain
because they feel like the gift
that that pain provides is a certain
degree
of insight or cynicism and also
wittiness that leads to what they're
able to do
which is a really tough position
in a lot of respects to find yourself in
or to put yourself in
so i'd say on the more amusing side of
things
a good example would just be my
as i mentioned the the editorial eye
well let's take that same editorial eye
well that seems like a huge gift when
you're reviewing a manuscript but
when you look at a countertop
and i'll give a friend of mine a nod
here i won't mention
his full name but uh popey let's call
him popey
boby and i remember i was he's a
character i was with
uh i was with poppy and panama at one
point this is a very long time ago
2004 so for those who have read the four
hour work week this is
before right before i went to argentina
and had the entire saga of tango unfold
i was in panama
and it was actually a friend of his
initials j.m mitchell
who said i had to go to argentina but
backing up to the point i was
gonna make i would sit there and i would
write and i was working on
various things at the time i was running
this this sports supplement business
and i had all of my notebooks and all of
my pens and
everything laid out almost like an
unboxing
photograph or like a pack trip
photograph that you'd see on instagram
like everything was either parallel or
perpendicular i mean it was
like it was like it was set up by you
know some type of japanese artist on
graph paper i mean it was perfectly
organized
to my liking and poppy would come over
and he would just he'd just like
very slowly he'd look at me kind of like
a cat kind of like your cat
loki and he'd look at me and he just
with his index finger like
push the edge of one pen to knock it off
knock it off angle like 10 and then he
would just go back to whatever he was
doing and i knew he was trying to [ __ ]
with me so i would leave it i'd be like
i'm not going to succumb i'm not going
to succumb and i'd leave it and i'd
leave it and then i'd just be like
i can't do it and i would fix it and
after like a half hour of this
he came over and he's like tim
you're behaving like american psycho
and so this monk like
sensitivity especially visual
sensitivity
can be really problematic right and that
can certainly lead to domestic strife
and that's that's on me right that's on
me i should no no by the way we're
having this conversation in front of my
desk and i have the exact opposite
dynamic of tim so
entering my world is just pure chaos
created
consciously he's functioning quite
beautifully with
without a single thing in a straight
line now you're gonna mention the stuff
underneath the desk
is terrible
if we take it as true for the moment
which i think it is that
hyper function and dysfunction are often
right next to each other i think another
way to think about that
is that your superpower is very often
right next to your wound like your
biggest wound
yes and i think that that's an
interesting way to
reflect on it or journal on it or think
about it is
how did this possibly develop if it
developed through
a wound or traumatic event or
challenge of some type in my life right
and many of these things are fed by
innate qualities
right i think that usain bolt doesn't
matter how many
coaches he has for sprinting if he's
built like me it's going to be
the story turns out differently
nonetheless i think
the superpower being right next to your
wound is
very very often the case and i mean
they're
often two sides of the same coin
and i think it is possible
to work on the areas of dysfunction
whether they're minor or major
without subjugating and muting your
superpowers
i do think that's possible you have to
track it
i'm not saying it's always possible but
in my experience so far i think that it
is very possible
and i'll just say another thing which is
you know
a phrase that i used to use a lot
and i hear a lot of my type a friends
use a lot when it comes to considering
meditation
therapy fill in the blank is that
they're afraid of losing their edge
i just don't lose my edge and i'm afraid
i'm going to become complacent i don't
want to lose my edge lose my edges
this phrase is used a lot and in my
experience
the edge that they have in mind almost
inevitably cuts both ways
right like that intensity in that edge
that they
view as a pure advantage which helps
them
most often professionally usually has a
lot of consequences
personally so those are some of the ways
that i relate to it but i definitely
agree that they are
side by side you know this framing of
viewers around
the wound is is really beautiful really
powerful and i relate to it i i've
in the last stretch i've been writing
about
training and one thing that i'm very
careful about
is to for anyone who's trying to convey
something to be to be able to see their
context
because any kind of teacher or coach or
writer or anyone who's not aware of
their own context can be trying to
impose something on somebody else that
doesn't fit them and so
i'm trying to be explicit introspective
about my context and my context relative
training
comes from a wound which was
in a nutshell i started playing chess
when i was six years old when i was
seven and eight i became
i was at that point i was the top rated
player in the us for my age and so i was
the target
my whole childhood from age seven until
you know until my 20s i was
the the the target and as a kid that
means that not only were other kids
focused on beating me because i would be
like the person to beat in the
tournament but their coaches who were
adults who were masters international
masters grandmasters
so every weakness that i showed
would be seen very clearly because the
adult coaches were much stronger players
than me
and would be focused on and exploited
and any strength that i had
would also be i had to refine it or else
it wouldn't work
right and so as a child as a really
young child
i had this experience it was almost
pavlovian of not taking on an
error led to pain taking on an error
or refining a strength led to flow
pleasure love of the game winning all
those things
so now as an adult what i'm aware of
is that not taking on a weakness is
almost outside of my conceptual scheme
unless i really consciously try josh can
you just make a mediocre turkey as one
friend recommended josh yes try not to
make the best turkey in the world just
make a mediocre [ __ ]
turkey for once our friend jim detmer
who's a brilliant
man who tim interviewed recently has
been saying to me for a long time josh
just try to cook like [ __ ]
just practice mediocrity and it's a
beautiful wise piece of counsel
given my madness it's something i
grapple with and then it's really
important for for me to see and it's
it's a core area of strength of mine
but of course it can lead to
complexities and interpersonal
relationships and
in my own life and so i have to feel to
see it yeah you know
it's as we're talking about this makes
me think of a
story in the book essentialism by greg
mcewen which which i'm very fond of
i think has a lot of gold in it
and i'm going to paraphrase here i'm not
going to get it exactly right but it
tells a story
of i believe it's a man in his 30s or
40s who
who flames out completely professionally
like he uh he
he just kills himself through overwork
and at the end of the story his advice
to others is
something along the lines of okay you're
a type a
hard charging competitive winner in life
he's like all right you want to try
something hard he's like
something hard is not working seven days
a week he's like try going home in the
middle of the day and take a nap
he's like you want to prove how tough
you are like try that because that's the
harder thing
for you to do so let's keep exploring
this relative to you so let me throw out
two themes and see where you go with
them
one is efficiency so you're a master of
efficiency
you're also an athlete and you've had
you've had identity as an athlete your
whole life but you have a very specific
physiological dynamic relative to your
lungs
that could lead somebody to really need
to take on the art of
being crazy efficient so what do you
think about that dynamic and how it
might have informed
where you've become incredibly over
developed maybe talk about
yeah so for people who are not but not
aware i
have a number of very obvious scars on
me you can still see that one
on the wrist which looks like a
cigarette burn but it's it's actually
where i was intubated i'm another one on
the left side where my left lung
collapsed
when i was born or probably collapsed
possibly
before i was born or in the birth
process
and i was preemie in the nicu
neonatal intensive care unit for a
really long period of time so i have
issues
with in particular thermoregulation is
how that shows up so if people
and that may or may not be related to
the lungs but i do have some some
pulmonary complications the
if you've ever seen a dog pant that is
to dissipate heat dogs don't really
dissipate heat through sweat very much
so in my case i overheat very easily
i've been
hospitalized for heat stroke a few times
and
what that meant from an athletic
perspective when i was wrestling
which was given how small i was up until
6th grade it was really one of the
only or the only sport where i could
compete and possibly win
because you have the the puniest of the
puny competing against the penis to the
puny
i developed an approach to wrestling
that compensated for
my tendency to overheat and therefore
generally lack of endurance right so i
think that led to thinking about
efficiency
although at the time i don't think i
would have labeled it that way and then
much later with language learning and
japanese and so on when i was 15 also
led me to think about efficiency a lot
so i think those were the two
sort of seminal chapters the wrestling
and then the language learning
that led me to think about effectiveness
and deficiency
both i think that even though it gets
talked about less i think about
effectiveness that is
choosing the right things choosing
material
so to speak 80 20 analysis
style more than efficiency because
doing something really well doesn't
automatically make it important
right but i do i do think about both and
you know the
to use your phrasing from earlier the
shadow side of that
is that in the case of wrestling
i identified weight cutting and
greco-roman upper body techniques as
places where i could really
shine and if you continue to
kind of chunk down chunk down chunk down
so that you get to a place where instead
of using i'm making up these numbers but
100 techniques you're using 10
techniques
and they're very shoulder dependent and
then on top of that
you're cutting in my case i was cutting
from my senior year in high school 178
to 152
twice a week which is insane that's
crazy it's insane and it's very
dangerous i don't recommend it
i ended up having and still have chronic
shoulder issues
yes sosa i know i can't take care of
their shoulders
oh i think i think ghost is letting out
some
wicked dog fog mist also in any case i
digress
so i do think that striving for like the
sort of minimalist 80 20 analysis
in the physical realm can be quite
dangerous
because you can end up with overuse
syndrome and dislocating shoulders in my
case having reconstructed shoulder
surgery and so on
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008
crisis you would have missed out on
fifty percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested
in a long-term automated investment
portfolio wealthfront pioneered the
automated investing movement sometimes
referred to as robo advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an
incredibly low cost wealthfront software
constantly monitors your portfolio day
in and day out so you don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.com tim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
i think more and more these days about
how i can change things in my life so i
don't
need to think or i'm not inclined to
think about efficiency
same with competition think more about
that
i think we as humans gravitate to what
we are good at
in general i think that we all
like the validation intrinsic
and extrinsic or perhaps otherwise
that comes from feeling good about
doing something well and i'm really good
at figuring out
process improvements right so i'm very
good
kind of what was his name deming
manufacturing world
toyota and so on like i'm very good at
identifying
steps looking at a process figuring out
which steps can be removed
which steps should be removed which
should be inverted i'm very good at that
and i'm also we could talk at length
about this but in certain ways a good
competitor
i'm very driven by competition i find it
exciting
i like stakes i do well
when there are consequences usually and
i'm almost always able to perform better
in competition than i am in training
but i think competition
much like positional economics right in
other words someone is inclined if they
make 75
000 a year let's just say to feel much
better about that if all their friends
make 50 000
a year versus if all their friends make
100 000 a year
even though their life and quality of
life may not
change at all objectively at that 75 000
it just depends on the peer group right
so competition i feel like
has value in certain areas certainly and
it's been incredibly
valuable to me but if you default to
efficiency and competition that
you can make yourself miserable
depending on who you feel you're
competing with
and you can focus on doing things really
well
whether or not you should be doing them
in the first place whether or not they
are
in fact the piece of the puzzle
that makes a real difference so those
are those are a few of the things that
i'm
shifting and thinking about a lot right
now in my life i mean the last
six months has really been the last six
months especially the last three months
has been a
a hitting of the pause button like the
pause button is currently on
for me and this is the awkward part not
so much think about
these things figure these things out but
to sort of uh
watch the conditions of my life and see
if i
notice anything that pulls me
in a different direction or that kind of
compels me in a different direction or
draws me in a different direction
so i mean you and i've spoken about this
a bit like and i'm probably mangling
your intention of what you said but you
know rather than
doing something right now trying to like
slightly change the conditions
to see what emerges from the that new
set of conditions or to set the correct
conditions but right now
the question for me would be correct for
what i don't know because the what
is the next step and right now that's a
void for me i just don't know
and so i'm you know i come here to the
jungle to spend time with you it's like
all right let's like have a shift of
a couple of variables create some space
and see what emerges from that and it's
a beautiful
entry into this idea of when we talk
about the entanglement of
strengths and weaknesses or genius and
eccentricity or dysfunctionality however
we want to frame it
it opens up the discussion of how much
we should be focusing on our strengths
and how much we should be focusing on
our weaknesses
right and i i tend to believe that
in life we should really embrace our
funk and we should we should
an over developed power zone is is
incredibly powerful
potent on the other hand we do need to
acknowledge our weaknesses and one thing
i've really come to
admire about you is how you do that for
example what you're saying right now
you're a person who really
loves to get [ __ ] done but you've hit
pause and the pause button is revealing
some things
the theme of control is also quite
interesting like when you speak about a
power zone of yours is risk mitigation
right
trying to think about how things can go
wrong on projects
you also have a very interesting
relationship to control
yeah and hypervigilance and hypervision
that would be another example
of something that in excess kind of
becomes its
opposite right like an obsession with
security
breeds a feeling of insecurity
that's that's actually i'm glad you
brought that up because that would be a
probably the most
crippling in a sense like emotionally
psychologically crippling
of the wounds slash dysfunctions
right next to superpowers and in some
ways i i would think as your friend and
i'm just putting this out as a question
that you're grappling with those
dynamics as part of what's led you to
this incredibly powerful work you've
been
driving in the world around psychedelics
maybe speak to
that relationship between control and
what
your medicine journey has opened up yeah
yeah well you you
i thought you put it really well a
couple days ago or weeks ago
time changes in the jungle i can't even
remember
when you said something along the lines
of you know i find it very interesting
that as someone who is controlled so
much
and focused on control so much that one
of your primary focuses
if not your primary focus right now is
compounds that create experiences that
are not controlled and they can be safe
but you know if you think you're going
to take
a mega dose of psilocybin or ndmt
or lsd or any of these things and then
write the screenplay of your experience
and live that
out line by line you're gonna be very
disappointed
you know uh maybe maybe more like
ulysses strapped to the mast
and i think there is a tremendous
i experience a tremendous relief
when i can completely
let go of control or attempt to let go
of control and
feel the beauty of floating downstream
instead of trying to swim upriver
against the current
right because i think most of my life
i have prided myself on
being you know the like the fastest
salmon
right just [ __ ] thrashing like mad
like making it up the rocks dodging the
grizzly bear
and being willing to
suffer more than other people so you
could
you could dress that up and say you know
developing a pain tolerance or compete
but ultimately i think if we're honest
with ourselves
and i'm not saying there isn't a place
for this right but i think certainly i
have to be very careful
about assigning too much
dignity and profundity to out-suffering
people
i think if we lionize that and
really put it on a pedestal you can you
can paint yourself into a really nasty
corner
so with the with the medicine
experiences
and the let me rephrase that just
because that lingo might not make sense
to people but
in these transcendental
sometimes certainly transcendental or
transpersonal meaning
that you experience ego dissolution
right the concept of
i and tim and time
and space dissolves which you know it's
kind of like sex or
it's really just not going to make any
sense unless you've had an experience of
this type
so i won't belabor the description and
it's kind of like
if some guy's never ejaculated and
you're like well it's kind of like
sneeze
in your balls and they're like i think i
get it
but you know you can't really quite wrap
your head around it
but i digress the point is having these
experiences
where i'm not trying to out suffer
i'm trying to out surrender not out
surrender i'm trying to surrender
and also lots of people have said this
but i think
that experiences of anxiety depression
etc are very often
me focused they're you know in some
respects very self-absorbed right
they're very
me me me focused and they're also in the
case of
well in the case of depression often
past focused in the case of anxiety very
future focused
and you know if you take five grams of
potent philosophy mushrooms
maintaining any type of me me centric
focus in the past
or the future is going to be next to
impossible
right so you're given a reprieve and
once you experience that reprieve
you know that it's possible
and then you can begin to look for
avenues
for extending the effects
into normal everyday
sober life and looking for other
modalities or tools
to find those spaces and so for me it's
it's just been
a revelation in that respect
beautiful so a pattern that i that i
hear you speaking to is that
your previous relationship for example
to efficiency
or control is evolving increasingly into
an exploration of setting the conditions
for success or
for for x being downriver
surrender yeah so so this is
just in the exploration of the
entanglement of over development and
under development and you talked about
people
friends of yours who've said but i don't
want to lose my edge so
as you feel yourself making that
movement
which is really a deep exploration of
these core themes
do you feel like it's taking away your
edge or adding to it
i think it's multiplying my edge and
this is going to be
maybe a really seem like a really
mundane
or odd example but
he's been on the mind because he just
stepped down to ceo jeff bezos
and i'm not comparing myself to jeff
bezos just to be very clear
but and one of the massive advantages
that bezos
has had for so long and still has
is his time frame he somehow managed
to convince and persuade wall street
to give him different time horizons
than everyone else being judged quarter
by quarter now amazon is still judged
on quarterly results to some extent but
for the longest time the growth of
amazon i mean it was
in if you read the shareholder letters
and i encourage everybody to look at
these collected pdfs of the amazon
shareholder letters
he just had a longer time horizon and
when you have a 10 15 year 20-year time
horizon
you can think about making decisions in
a very different way
you relate to feeling rushed or
pressured
in a very different way and
i feel like now i have to be careful
here to also recognize that my
circumstances have changed a lot in the
last
10 15 years okay so i might be inclined
to say well
i can just wait for fat pitches and i
feel like i have more of an edge and
that may be also a byproduct of my
changing circumstances so i don't want
to
attribute that solely to this ability to
wait
but my experience is now
that the way that i've heard other
people describe
the shift that i'm trying to embrace is
being patient but i don't think about it
that way it might be that but
patience to me i think can sometimes i
have a bit of an allergic reaction to
patients
just because i think it's used so often
as an excuse for complacency or laziness
so the word
is not my favorite to apply here but
paying attention right like really
paying attention
to things around me and the feelings
around me
and let's just say you know the dog
that's laying right next to us you know
like osa
and zeus at meal time like whether they
need water or not like i'm
constantly tracking all that stuff and
it's a very
light tracking and
when i cultivate that i feel like
i have less it still comes up
occasionally but less fear of missing
out
because i have a confidence that i am
going to see
things that most people are going to
miss simply because they are rushing
it's interesting how universal this
theme is and if you if you think about
it in a multidisciplinary way
there are of course always exceptions
but almost always when you watch
for example an athlete over the years
and over the decades their progression
is from doing more to doing less
being more just getting more done and
with one of the fascinating
and kind of mystical looking things
about really
superb virtuoso fighters martial artists
is that they can move much slower
and always get there first yeah yeah and
it's it's gorgeous to see and it's
beautiful to to really work on embodying
and it's not because they can't move
quickly they can move like lightning but
they can move slower and get there first
yeah i remember thinking that with i
don't know if this name is going to mean
anything because it's a really this is a
this is dating me when i was in japan
when i was 15 that's when i
really i had always had an affinity for
martial arts and had
trained in various schools as a kid but
had never really
seen real
hard-hitting fighting
in the sense of mma which didn't exist
as it does now but you know sogo
in japan seeing pancras and so on but
also
k1 with the big guys and there's a
fighter way back in the day named peter
eritz
the dutch lumberjack huge guy and
gigantic i mean just a mountain of a guy
and
he had such impeccable timing
which is certainly in part
very fast perception
right and and also acute perception
that even though he wasn't the fastest
fighter he almost always got there first
and he was a huge guy but he was just
able to read
the ring and the opponent and the space
so
perfectly it was amazing to watch
yeah it's a beautiful principle and i
think it really manifests everywhere
yeah and the the uh you know one of the
mantras that i've been repeating to
myself
a lot recently is from well i learned
from a friend whose former military
which
is slow as smooth and smooth as fast
and really trying to apply that to
my writing trying to apply that to
different types of training trying to
apply that to
decision making also right which is why
i give
almost always if just as a rule if
someone tries to rush my decision making
it's just no the answer is no
automatically right
yeah as one example that's part of what
i'm
revisiting as within this pause period
so in this pause period where
you're really sitting and i've been
watching you sit in an empty space
without rush what's surfacing and and
what are some of the core tension points
or areas that you're aware of being torn
massive tension points uh i mean my
every fiber of my programmed
being right like my socialized self that
has been rewarded for so long
by doing things it
can be very hard to sit with empty space
and it makes me think a lot and i've
been thinking about this
in the last few weeks a lot a
quote from tara brock who's a
mindfulness
and meditation teacher i mean she's much
more than that but wrote an amazing book
called radical acceptance that i
recommend to everyone
and she has this i'll just call it an
expression
it's probably a story in one of her
books but she says you know
a famous sage once said there's only
one important question and that question
is what are you unwilling to feel
and i think for a lot of people
maybe the majority of people maybe all
people i don't know
many of our compulsive behaviors
are to
mask or override things that we don't
want to feel
right so if there is something you feel
you need to focus on something you feel
you need to do
if there are it's a pack of cigarettes
you need to pick up
it's ties into what gabor mate
who who i recommend people check out
he's been on the podcast as well
will sometimes talk to you with respect
to addiction he says you know people ask
why
the addiction they shouldn't ask why the
addiction they should ask why the pain
because the addiction is a consequence
of
the pain and trying to mask the pain
although i'm
i'm paraphrasing so bring this back down
to earth sitting here with empty space
a lot of uncomfortable feelings come up
and it's been challenging to sit with
them and not
immediately try to fix them you know
fears
feeling a lack of direction feeling a
lack of
security fears anger has come up a lot
although i think that's probably
in part due to a therapy session a few
days ago where i talked about the
childhood trauma which
really is is dangerous yeah it's
tricky terrain to navigate and can have
a lot of after effects if i revisit it
a lot of emotions and there have been
great days
you know yesterday it was a great day
there have been some really hard days
where i'm just like what the [ __ ] am i
doing
what the [ __ ] am i not doing and why am
i not doing like am i actually going to
figure out anything
because i just feel like i'm sitting by
the pool staring at trees
you know like is is there
am i expecting some lightning bolt from
the heavens to come down and
give me this you know miraculous
epiphany that will solve all my issues
like what am i doing
and so it's been it's been really
challenging
it's been super challenging not every
day and i'm very fortunate that
we've been able to spend time together
and i've been able to spend time with
your family and with
a number of our friends who are here
in strict isolation lockdown
[Music]
so that's been gorgeous and i've had so
much fun and
when i'm by myself and it's quiet a lot
comes up
because i'm i i normally have
so many other activities many of which
are great many of which are
productive many of which are in some way
contributing whatever the
adjective we might want to use that
allows me also encourages me to do those
things when you take all those away
yeah a lot of stuff can come up to the
state you're in is a
it's a version of what so many people
are feeling right now this is such a
painful time in the world
so many people are alone and in pain in
different
forms sometimes they've some so many
have lost loved ones
so many are forced into isolation or
lack of socialization
and it's there's a lot of heartbreak out
there and and just
so i you speaking about your own journey
here is powerful
i'm curious just given where you're at
i often go with people who i'm kind of
exploring with
do something we call a cave process
which is essentially i was going to ask
you about that
yeah disappearing and the way i look
first thing written down there is the
cave process what the hell is the cave
process
essentially sitting in a space
that is empty enough to get away from
the inertia or reactivity the inertia of
where we're coming from or reactivity
away from where we're coming from
you're in a version of that state right
now and
you you last time you and i jammed we
talked about this
this framing that i play with sometimes
of of how would your future self guide
you
because no one will know you more
intimately than yourself 20 years from
now
and odds are yourself 20 years from now
will be less
attached the things that you're
extremely attached to now so
just given your intuitive sense of the
direction you're going
in life what do you think or feel that
your
say 20-year future self would say to you
how would he guide you
today i i will answer that
first i want to ask you with the k
process how do you implement that with
people you're working with or people you
advise is it is it a
physical relocation to a place of
stillness is it blocking out the
calendar so they have
space to remove themselves from the
bombardment of stimuli what does that
cape process look like
well i think it can take many forms as
you pointed out earlier there there are
some people who are in a state of
privilege where they can really
disappear from the world for three or
four months
and reflect and there are other people
who are just who can't do that
they've got maybe they've got families
they've got job they're putting food on
the table they can't just disappear
and and so i think there's microwaves of
manifesting it for example waking up
first in the morning and journaling
is like a mini version of this just
creating empty space
where we can tap into our unconscious is
really powerful i've gone through
three four five month periods with
people where they truly stepped away
from everything
and reflected and tried to
blue sky where they wanted to go in life
as opposed to getting caught up in the
execution concerns
is it a structured reflection do you
have prompts
questions etc that you provide or
practices or is it really just
empty space let's see what emerges i
think the stillness comes first and then
the structure
can be layered in but the structure as
you know like i would structure it
differently for every person who i'd be
interacting with because we're all
different
that's how i honestly relate to that
that question
but i i think that the principle
of getting away from reactivity or
inertia is powerful for
relationships almost everyone moves from
one relationship to the next right
they rebound but sitting in space post
a relationship is is really powerful
post a love relationship or a post
friendship that falls apart i just think
that we have the impulse to fill space
the moment it empties but sitting in
emptiness can be really powerful
thank you for that so i'm going to
take a stab at your question i will say
as a preface that
i don't know if i've ever mentioned this
to you the piece of writing
that i somehow lost that
made me saddest was a piece of fiction
and i never write fiction but it was
a story i wrote i think i was on a train
ride and i was and i asked myself this
question sometimes i was like what would
what would an
older version of me say to me now this
was a long time ago
10 years ago something like that so i
wrote this story of
a fiction story of me going skiing
taking a break going to a sea lodge
sitting by the fire
having some wine and having this older
gentleman sit down next to me
and this is before i read any boris
because this is like straight boris
and struck up a conversation and about
like 10 20 minutes into it realized that
it was an older version of myself
and so we had this conversation about
what he'd learned what advice he would
give me and it was just like you know 10
12 page document and
it was it was just an incredible
exercise and then i somehow
lost it go figure if you're writing that
story today
yeah if i were writing that story today
i think the the car
piece that comes to mind if i'm not
overthinking it
right if it's just whatever kind of pops
into my head which i'm trying to pay a
lot more attention to
that first flash which is very different
from the
number crunched analytical flash which
isn't really a flash it's more of like a
squeezing out of the sponge but
that first flash is that he would say
focus on enjoyment
and fun and pleasure like the things
that give you those
feelings uh and the justification
not that there's one needed i mean i
think those those are all very good
things by and large and you're assuming
you know no uh there's no collateral
damage
i just have so much more energy when i
feel
one of those things and my
lifelong battle since my teens has been
with
chronic fatigue and that led to abusing
ephedrine caffeine aspirin in high
school which was introduced to me by an
upperclassman for wrestling and then uh
oh
now i'm using it two three times a day
that was a mess for you know decade plus
and i'd severe lyme disease a few years
ago
this happens all the time on long island
i mean to the extent that in the er and
the summers they just have a sign that's
like
do you have lyme disease like hey fill
out this survey and get a free amazon
gift card i mean it's it's
everywhere so i had severe lyme and
the blood test came back and the doctor
said well
you are positive you have an acute
infection but you're aware you've
already been infected
and i as more and more people now would
recognize with the serologic testing
you know i guess igg might be getting
that wrong i think it's igg instead of
ign but long-term antibodies
for lyme or present and
i've just had this incredible fatigue
since i was in my teens
so and that that persists to this day on
some level
and so i think that deepening my
relationships
thinking about family i think
moving from a deep feeling of
obligation and responsibility which i
think has driven a lot of my behavior
there's the competitive drive
but then there's also a feeling
especially after almost committing
suicide in college that i'm just
operating on borrowed time and like i
owe
a lot right and then i have a moral
obligation to do
a b c d e all the way to z
and i not not to say that's
run its course entirely uh maybe there
is a place for that and i think
i don't think i'm at risk of becoming
totally irresponsible
i just don't think that it's likely that
the pendulum would swing back that far
and i think if i have a family
and i haven't embraced fun and joy
and taking time and
taking attention for like the small
pleasures
that will really if like my kid will
receive or kids
will absorb that type of orientation to
the world
where it is responsibility where it is
obligation
and it will have a very sterilizing
effect
and muting effect on them and
so right now you know i found myself say
years ago thinking like when i have kids
i'll change a
when i have kids i'll change b when i
have kids i'll change
d e and f and i've i've come to the
conclusion that that i think is very
naive
like you better start becoming the
parent you want to be now
before game time right like you're not
going to just step in the ring
and be like okay now that i'm here with
mike tyson i'm going to learn how to box
that's a terrible idea and the beautiful
thing is that all that preparation
you'll do then you have a kid and the
kid just
kicks your ass anyway yeah and teaches
you how to parent that kid
right so so now now just to be clear
it's not so much learning how to be a
parent
it's becoming the person you want to be
trying to train yourself and instill the
habits
and the changes in perspective that you
want to have
when you are a parent so it's purely
it's within your locus of control yeah
yeah and then you get a kid who kicks
you in the nuts and like
okay now you gotta now you gotta change
your strategy
but but it's not a it's not a parenting
strategy it's more a way of thinking
about
the person i want to be when
i'm like holding a child in my arms for
the first time
versus who i am now and working on that
now
that's beautiful man yeah i think you're
going to be a hell of a dad i can't wait
yeah thanks brother
it'd be so fun to have our little ones
little rugrats duking it out together
i love it yeah okay let's we have about
11 more minutes let's pick up the pace
let's do it i want to hit you with let's
be a little more tactical about these
exactly so this one is technically
practical this is not such a tactical
question but it's slightly
it's relatively tactical so i personally
have this feeling
that i observe so many people yearning
for return to normal
right i don't personally think that
normal is necessarily returning so
quickly
and i feel that we're entering an age in
human history where
a core theme will be a radically
accelerating pace of change so
destabilizing events of different forms
will become the new normal
versus the the return to normal that so
many people are craving and so i'm not
really suggesting we debate that idea
but just
roll with me on that idea yeah and if
you just were to play with that framing
how do you think that people would best
prepare for the world
that we might be entering over the next
five 10 15 years
if that theme has some validity yeah
well
turns out you're asking mr hyper
vigilance so i have i have thought about
this a bit
we've talked about it a little bit so i
think i think the assertion's right
certainly with with technology and
sort of exponentially ramping technology
global interconnectedness
i mean all of that is going to continue
to the curve of all that is going to
continue to steepen for a million
reasons that we
we won't get into right now so i'll say
two things number one
is i think you have to
have to is a strong phrasing but i'm
gonna use it for simplicity because
we're doing a lightning round
you have to focus on metal learning and
meta skills or you're just gonna be
toast
you need to be able to learn to do
things
that machines have great difficulty
doing then by machine i include
software most software right now and
to embrace your humanness right i think
kevin kelly is actually a great person
to
read up on for identifying kind of
opportunities moving forward
he's you know a lot of people try to
predict technological advances
the big difference with kevin is that
he's very often right
and yeah so he's given a lot of thought
to say ai
and humans and the next 10 to 10 to 20
years
so i think meta learning skills i think
your book the art of learning
should be required reading i think there
are aspects
of meta learning that are explored in
four-hour chef which confusingly is not
just a cookbook it is in fact a book
about accelerated learning
that can make you
not just resilient but anti-fragile in
the sense
that the vast majority of people you
might ever compete with
if you end up competing will not have
this toolkit
so when there's a shock to the system
like covet
when there is a shock to the system like
some designer epidemic or pandemic that
is designed using
crispr right and released easily out of
some basement
and when there is a disaster like fill
in the blank right there's so many
technologies 3d printing
you know blockchain decentralized
social networks or even assassination
marketplaces
i mean miniature drones where like the
cost of defense is
a million times higher than the cost of
offense i mean these like i mean
the the kind of dystopian
possibilities for cheap
destabilizing events with many players
we've talked about this right like not
like one or two or three or four players
who are state actors but tens of
thousands of people who could
implement certain attacks they could be
really destabilizing
he or she who is the most adaptable
wins i think in many respects so metal
learning
and then really understanding i do think
you know for all of his eccentricity i
think talib
and black swan fooled by randomness read
those books if you are not
on a very basic level and you do not i
never took calculus i am not a
mathematician by any stretch
but learn to understand probabilistic
thinking
it's so [ __ ] important just start to
read fooled by randomness and black swan
get a basic understanding of how
probability affects your decision-making
in life
beautiful your point about learning is
so powerful i
i mean one way to just very simply think
about this is that
people tend to think about technique
tactics technique but if you
if you focus your learning on the
principles that house the techniques
then you can throw all the techniques
away and
reinvent new techniques quite easily as
you know
i've experimented a lot with a lot so
the techniques are just the external
husk
the meta the principle is the thing to
really focus on learning and it's really
remarkable how they can be manifest in
in
new places quite quickly i think the
metal learning and adaptability are
so intertwined okay so you sent me a doc
of
some questions from some of your
listeners and i want to hit you with a
few of those
if you don't mind let's do it so andrew
t asks what's the single most
important attribute you look for when
debating if you'll bring a new person
into your circle of friends
okay the first one uh so i used to
debate
a lot more in my head than i do now the
first thing honestly is
just gut feeling like does the
animal in me move forward towards that
person
does it stay where it is or does it pull
back even a quarter inch even a
millimeter
i love it that's a beautiful answer yeah
that's that's boom that's
that's that's number one and number two
is just trustworthiness
discretion intelligence is dime a dozen
i really just
like i care less and less about what we
consider intelligence
every time i've overruled my intuition
about someone it's bit me in the ass
yeah every time yeah and pay attention
to molly pay attention to my dog yeah
because even if i'm
i've had two drinks and my spider senses
off if if molly doesn't like someone
yeah pay very close attention to that
yeah yeah
russell w do you ever worry you're
mistaking noise for signal with learning
from successful people
survival bias and all that jazz it's an
interesting question i think about it a
lot i think this is
this is a very smart question very
observant question you need to keep in
mind
so for me the first thing with with
world class performers is a
can they repeat whatever i admire about
them in other words
like once you're lucky twice you're good
right like three times
you're world class if it's something
really outrageous
first can they actually repeat what is
their claim to fame
let's just figure that out first because
if not like keep looking
number two is can they teach it
are there any examples of disciples
which which you can see certainly in the
in the investing world right you see
these rollouts
and then also the question of are they
succeeding because
of x whatever x is that you're looking
at or are they succeeding
in spite of x and those two things are
very often confused
where people are like this works because
i use tough love and i kick my employees
in the face every time they [ __ ] up and
that's be
i run a tight ship and that's why it
works and it's like actually
jesus it would be ten times better if
you didn't do that so you're succeeding
in spite of that in which case you can
ask people around them
or who have had exposure to them yeah
beautiful answer
so ricky sent two questions i liked um
one of which of course is quite personal
to me now because
we've got a beautiful puppy what have
you learned about yourself in the world
now that you've had a dog for a while
i've learned that we project
a lot of our [ __ ] on everyone
and everything including dogs and dogs
are just i mean there may be exceptions
but dogs are just
so tabula rasa i mean they come
obviously pre-installed with
all their gray wolf dna and canid quirks
but
when i was raising molly and training
molly in the beginning like looking back
i'm so
embarrassed by how upset i got at points
when she was
not being disobedient not understanding
my training because i wasn't training
well i wasn't clear
and it's so easy to anthropomorphize
our animals and assume that they have
some internal
agenda or that they're doing a b and c
to annoy us
and so on which ends up being
such a mirror for what our
wounds are our fears are what our
compulsions are so i think
male is incredible and dogs are an
incredible mirror they really show you
i think your strengths and your
weaknesses and i think molly
has really taught me how to love also as
a result of that
i mean just to to just love
an animal so deeply and unconditionally
i think
i think that it's uh it's really
opened up a lot in me and removed a lot
of armor that would have been difficult
to remove otherwise
that's so beautiful and i see that in
you i see the way you interact with osa
and with
zeus my brother um lights dog zeus
just the way you bring love to these
these big pups who've got a whole lot of
energy they just and they just love you
it's a and there's no no bullshitting in
that
yeah yeah sorry about making out with oh
so that first night
that was that was nothing to behold i
came in just for people who are not in
the joke
and uh i was like can i give may i give
also a little treat and he's like sure
and this is the i guess the first first
night i'd arrived
there's the alarm that says i need to go
get my covet test which is kind of on
team oh no leave it
yeah yeah and so uh the alarm saying i
need to go get my covet test uh which is
appropriate because i just arrived
and he's like sure you can give us a
treat and i put a little piece of
chicken
in my teeth and also grabbed it and josh
was like
you can give my
it was pretty great it was pretty great
we had a fiery start that was a good
start to the whole thing
hey man this has been a lot of fun yeah
great great man
so good to see you and so good to jam
and uh
to be continued brother love you very
much love you too man
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
fiori clothing spelled v-u-o-r-i
biore i've been wearing fiori at least
one
item per day for the last few months and
you can use it for everything it's
performance apparel
but it can be used for working out it
can be used for
going out to dinner at least in my case
i feel very comfortable with it
super comfortable super stylish and i
just want to read
something that one of my employees said
she is an athlete
she is quite technical although she
would never say that i asked her if she
had ever
used or heard of biore and this was her
response
i do love their stuff been using them
for about a year i think i found them at
rei
first for my partner t-shirts that are
super soft but somehow
last as he's hard on stuff and then i
got into the super soft cotton yoga
pants and jogger
sweatpants i live in them and they too
have lasted they're stylish enough i can
wear them out and about
the material is just super soft and
durable i just got their clementine
running shorts for summer and love them
the brand seems pretty popular
constantly sold out in closing and i'm
abbreviating here but in closing
with the exception of when i need
technical outdoor gear they're the only
brand i've bought in the last year or so
for yoga running
loungewear that lasts and that i think
look good also
i like the discrete logo so that gives
you
some idea that was not intended for the
sponsor read
that was just her response via text
viori again spelled b-u-o-r-i
is designed for maximum comfort and
versatility you can wear it running you
can wear their stuff training
doing yoga lounging weekend errands or
in my case again going out
to dinner it really doesn't matter what
you're doing their clothing
is so comfortable and looks so good and
it's it's non-offensive you don't have a
huge
brand logo in your face you'll just want
to be in them all the time
and my girlfriend and i have been
wearing them for the last few months
they're men's
core short kore the most comfortable
lined athletic short
is your one short for every sport i've
been using with kettlebell swings for
runs you name it the banks short this is
their go to land
to see short is the ultimate in
versatility it's made from recycled
plastic bottles and what i'm wearing
right now
which i had to pick one to recommend to
folks out there or at least to men out
there is the ponto performance
pant and you'll find these at the link
i'm going gonna give you guys
you can check out what i'm talking about
but i'm wearing them right now
they're thin performance sweatpants but
that doesn't do them justice so you
gotta check it out ponto ponto
performance pant
for you ladies the women's performance
jogger is the softest jaw girl you'll
ever own
fiori isn't just an investment in your
clothing it's an investment in your
happiness and for you my dear listeners
they're offering 20
off your first purchase so get yourself
some of the most comfortable and
versatile clothing on the planet
it's super popular a lot of my friends
have now noticed are wearing this
and so am i biore clothing dot com
forward slash
tim that's b u o r i clothing dot com
slash tim not only will you receive 20
off your first purchase
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on
any u.s orders over 75
and free returns so check it out
fioreclothing.com
tim that's v-u-o-r-i clothing dot com
slash tim
and discover the versatility of the ore
clothing
this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer end quote that's
the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights up and down
with the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still
getting a tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
for our body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then total
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout
on total focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert lead workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that tritonal the
world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com for 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tell us be your strongest
you